Mehrwertsteuer wird angehoben auch in
Gaststätten betrieben was ein
wahnsinniger Punkt ist der CO2 Preis ja
das sind alles dingekung
zurügenes hat der Bachmann Punkt ne es
wird eine Senkung zurückgenommen was die
Gastronomie
angeht ge aber recht ich geb ihn aber
recht her weil ich glaube die Leute sind
zu einer Menge bereit auch zu
Klimaschutz und auch zu Unterstützung
der Ukraine aber Sie müssen das Gefühl
haben es geht gerecht dabei zu wenn Sie
das Gefühl haben
v sind dabei total aufgenommen nur wegen
Symbols das ist das symbolis schon
wichtig wir wir fassen wir finden uns
damit ab dass in der größten Krise die
wir hatten die Zahl der Milliardäre
steigt und ich sag noch mal Milliardär
also wirklich das wird man nicht durch
eigene händearbeit das ist einfach wahr
und die Multimillionäre werden mehr da
muss man wenigstens symbolisch sagen wir
wir wir reden darüber und nicht das
kommt nicht in die Tüte dann ist dann
ist das ist wirklich Christian Lindner
der Interessenvertreter des Geldadel